Right off the bat.
Let's dispense with the whole
objectivity thing.
No one's always write objectively,
but you can use tricks and sophistry
when logic and facts aren't on your side
to always be right in an argument.
The whole goal here is to try to win.
It's an intellectual war.
Air Go all is fair in love and
arguments.
I think Sun Tzu said that once.
This is going to be an abridged list of
dirty little tricks taken from Archer
Schopenhauer,
his book,
the art of being right.
The full book and audio book is linked
below.
I've just picked my favorites.
Let's get into it.
First postulate.
What has to be proved.
This is where you bring up a conclusion
as if it were a premise.
It's also known as begging the question.
Here's an example.
I began this campaign because I was so
tired of seeing such foolish things
happen to our country.
Notice how he says,
the reason I began this campaign is
because the country was doing so poorly.
He never proves how the country is doing
poorly or why it's doing poorly.
He states it as a matter of fact,
upfront postulate.
What has to be proved.
This is a great way to sneak your point
past the goalposts.
Next,
choose your definitions.
This works best at the start of an
argument.
If you want to control the conversation,
try to control the definitions,
what someone might call extremism.
Another person might call passion,
what some call a right to assembly.
Others might call it disrespectful or
disruptive.
Here's an example from a recent debate.
Pay attention to how much time is spent
framing the other person's position and
conversely how much the other one fights
against this framing.
They both know that the words you use to
define the other person's position is
everything he ran as a socialist,
an honor leaders,
socialists dollar randoms,
it independent and sort of being
independent.
The history of the United States called
are you a socialist or not?
I am a democratic social.
Okay folks,
but don't tell him I didn't run as often
as I ran to me.
When you told people you were socialists
fun runners,
a right winger,
you ran as a Republican,
right?
I am happily up and I am happily
frame the conversation in your way.
No matter if you're talking about gender
or unemployment,
how you define it is everything.
Number three,
persuade the audience,
not the opponent.
If you're in front of an audience,
tactically,
it doesn't matter if the person to your
left or right agrees with you.
Only the crowd.
This is pretty easy.
It's the quip,
the one liner.
Whatever gets the laugh.
The most important thing to remember
here is the audience isn't just there to
see who objectively wins.
It's a spectacle.
They want to laugh.
They want to see who looks more composed
under the lights.
I have as much spirits in the congress
as Jack Kennedy did when he sought the
presidency.
Senator,
I served with Jack Kennedy.
I knew Jackie Kennedy Sanitary.
You got to know Jack Kennedy.
If you notice it,
that's
the opponent seems to wither after this
mine,
but he really didn't say much at all.
Number four,
the Kafka trap.
This is a particularly rude trick frame
and accusations such that the denial is
only further evidence of guilt.
Think the red scare or witch hunts.
When you accuse someone of something and
they refuse it,
just say,
oh,
that's what someone like that would say.
Here's an example from monty python.
Oh,
nice.
If you deny it,
you did it.
That's a Kafka trip.
Five arguments ad homonym.
If all else fails you.
Personal attacks are always a great
diversion to get off a particular point.
You're losing.
The examples here are endless.
I think we can have a rational political
conversation about balancing rights and
risks and rewards of all of these
different policies,
but I don't think that what we need to
do is demonized.
People on the other side is as being
unfeeling about the,
about what happened in San Antonio.
You accuse me of standing on the graves
of the children that die that day.
I seen you do it repeatedly.
Peers,
like I say,
how do you hire people illegally and
enter to 1 million
along with everybody?
You get along with nobody.
You don't have one republic,
have
one Republican senator and you work with
them every day of your life,
although you skipped a lot of time.
These are minor details,
but you don't have one Republican
senator back in you,
not one.
You don't have the endorsement of one
Republican senator and you work with
these senator Cruz.
You should be ashamed of yourself.
Notice how in both cases,
ad hominine was used to distract.
To deflect the underpinning question.
This technique is very effective and
finally we come to number six,
the absurd proposition.
This is where you offer an extreme
scenario where you equate things that
aren't equal at all,
but if you disguise it well enough and
if your opponent can't find where your
argument is falling apart,
it can pressure them into agreeing with
your point.
Here's another example.
I love South Park.
Are you guys dub?
We can't beat him even with all of us.
It's a waste of time that if you had a
chance right now to go back in time and
stop Hitler,
wouldn't you do it?
I'm just going to stop plague when hit
the rest power.
There were a lot of people who just
stopped playing.
You know who those people were?
The French.
Are you French guy?
No.
[inaudible].
All right.
I'll do it.
If your opponent doesn't spot the trick.
This is a particularly effective tactic.
That's everything I'm going to give you
scoundrels right now.
The full list is in Archer Schopenhauer,
his book.
The secret is to disguise these within
an argument so that people don't know
that you're playing tricks,
and if you can do this well,
you'll find yourself being right more
often than you thought possible.
But even if you're trying to be fair and
honest and an argument,
knowing these is always helpful to keep
the other guy honest.
Knowing how people want to fight dirty
is the best defense to fight clean.
But either way,
whether you're running for office or in
a late night argument,
please fallacy responsibility.